rien ne va plus pour téléphone le groupe
rock français a décidé de se dissoudre
une auto dissolution du peut-être à des
divergences musicales mais aussi une
certaine lassitude un peu comme les
beatles chacun des membres de téléphone
continuera seuls reportage avec les
enfants du rock jean pierre dionnet
philippe manoeuvre et yves dreux
depuis quelques jours la rumeur
circulait c'est désormais officiel
téléphone n'existe plus après trois
millions d'albums vendus et dix ans de
triomphe
le premier groupe de rock français
explose ça s'est passé une manière assez
calme quoi je dirai pas ce qu'on a on a
décidé ça comme ça parce que tout le
monde avait envie et surtout y avait pas
l'enthousiasmé et la volonté de faire ce
nouvel album tout de suite
et comme on n'a jamais rien fait sans
enthousiasme en dix ans de téléphone en
a on n'a rien fait qui nous plaisent pas
et on se dise pas maintenant qu'on va
commencer un mac c'est dur à dire tu
vois c'est toute une longue histoire
ça faisait dix ans c'était devenu
presque une entreprise
des fois j'avais l'impression d'aller à
l'usiné quand j'allais aux répétitions
au sud
c'était pas comme avant ça change et
puis ça change est de plus en plus il
fallait que ça s'arrête là
qu'est ce qui va se passer que les fans
quand il prête un peu surprise à leur
tomber dessus
il a béni les cas se passer - encore -
est-ce qu on a commencé à recevoir des
lettres il ya un truc que j'aime pas
c'est le certains fans qui parle
d'abandon donc de soi que nous on
abandonne soit qu'on les abandonne
je crois que faut bien qu'ils se rendent
compte que c'est pour être positif qu'on
fait ça et pas pour être négatif
et surtout on ne veut pas ternir ce
qu'on a fait parce que bon dieu sait
qu'ils avaient tous les concerts ont pas
été fabuleux on a toujours tout donné le
maximum et on a on a passé un des années
merveilleuses ensemble c'était ça a été
fantastique et il ya pour l'instant y'a
rien il ya aucun point noir ya rien qu'à
ternie on essaie de l'éviter peut-être
on les vit trop tôt je sais pas mais je
crois que les gens n'auraient pas nous
voir traîner la patte est naze faire les
compagnons de la chanson et tout ça
je viens d'apprendre que la chanteuse
pjak